[Music]
in the san francisco bay area the
housing crisis has become so severe that
some have adopted a novel solution
they're living on boats and not quaint
boats soft Sausalito where yachts
according to The Wall Street Journal
that a hundred people are living on a
ragtag flotilla of barges sailboats and
other vessels the paper describes this
quote decrepit they aren't all vagrants
some hold jobs one woman bought a boat
for fifteen grand because rent first
judea apartment had grown to three
thousand dollars a month do the math it
will pay for itself in less than a half
a year it might sound like an adventure
but it's also third world just like tent
camps most boats are not designed to be
lived on permanently during storms they
can endanger lives and cause damage huge
amounts of damage these flotillas are
illegal by the way but it's like
exploding housing prices Bay Area
government doesn't seem very interested
in it or serious about fixing it whether
it's San Francisco or New York or
Seattle when you think of homelessness
you think of major cities but the
homeless crisis is not limited to big
population centers some of the hardest
hit places are small cities in towns or
even a small homeless population can put
massive strain on public service for the
latest installment in our series
homeless in America our producer Charlie
Cougar went to Oregon where one small
charity is fighting to improve a
desperate situation in Eugene one our
first stop in Portland Oregon wasn't
meant to be work-related it was for
breakfast at an upscale bakery near the
city's fashionable pearl district but
when we arrived we found this a homeless
man rifling through a trash can in the
parking lot
a dirty syringe almost as in Portland
looked a lot like what we'd seen in
other cities
lots of tents lots of drugs the city's
permissive culture its temperate climate
and generous social services attract
vagrants and addicts from around the
country we met a woman called Liberty
hope at a cloverleaf off Interstate i-5
she says she came to the west coast
because she needed medical treatment for
her leukemia to move to Portland after
police in Washington state towed her
motor home
nowhere to go but I couldn't because I
still had treatment side to do hope says
she's blessed because the city shuttles
her between a medical clinic and her
tent she hopes to get back to her home
state of Montana once she's healthy
again how long do you think he'll be
here similar tent encampments line
Portland's highways virtually every open
space in the city seems packed with
people living outside and using drugs
this riverfront park downtown has a
receptacle for used heroin syringes
Oregon is a relatively small state by
population but it has an awful lot of
homeless people more per capita than
neighboring Washington or California to
get a sense of the scale of the problem
we drove to Eugene in the central part
of the state
Eugene is a college town with the
politics to match not surprisingly it
has an enormous homeless population
ultimately however even the generosity
of a place like Eugene has limits on the
night we arrived multiple people were
living in this makeshift structure two
days later the city had cleared the
sidewalk and put up notices that it was
going to scrap the belongings inside
Eugene is trying to get a handle on his
homeless problem but there are
roadblocks a major one a ruling by the
federal 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
that has declared it's somehow
unconstitutional to shoo away homeless
people if there's no place for them to
go
Eugene's leaders have responded by
trying to erect tent cities on public
land one proposal envisioned building a
homeless encampment in a parking lot at
the center of downtown so far those
efforts have failed a local charity
called st. Vincent DePaul has stepped in
with its own solution let's chant is a
structure that was used by the military
and some of our foreign deployments
other cities on the west coast have
tried to provide housing for the
homeless usually at remarkable expense
San Jose California for example is
spending 37 million dollars on a
building that will house just 83 people
by contrast st. Vincent DePaul's answer
is simple and cheap
this whole section tents up we'll work
through in one day residents are
assigned to bed and given a place to
store their belongings they're expected
to make their beds every day to instill
a sense of pride and self-worth the
shelter is open to anyone including
drunks and drug users those who stay get
treated for addiction the strategy
essentially is the opposite of what
cities like Seattle and San Francisco
are doing st. Vincent DePaul's goal is
to get people off the streets and into
an environment where they might actually
recover the housing isn't meant to be
permanent st. Vincent DePaul tries to
get residents cleaned up and ready for
long-term housing within just a few
months for many of the strategy appears
to be working what are the odds that in
two years they're back on the streets if
they stay in programs and an association
with people that are clean and sober
chances are pretty good that they're
gonna stay out well the homeless crisis
appears to be getting worse pretty much
everywhere in America rather than try to
fix the problem though elites prefer to
attack its victims in the city of
Seattle
one of the places hit hardest by this
crisis a woman has faced believe it or
not backlash for seeking justice after
she says she was raped by a homeless man
with multiple arrests warrants will
interview documentary filmmaker who told
her story tomorrow night as our series
on homelessness in America continues